let me just share with you the these
clips I want to play this one clip first
of all I want to show you what a brother
sent me he's a Catholic brother and I
just found out that the
prophecy the prophecy that the Catholic
Mystics and Visionaries appeal to to
show the apostasy will start in the
Catholic church I just found this out I
didn't Noti this is Luke 18
ver8 Luke 18 ver8 Luke 18:8 when a son
of man returns shall he find any faith
left on the earth I was unaware until
today that this is the passage that
Catholic Mystics and Visionaries have
been appealing to as an indication that
our Lord has already warn there'll be an
apostasy in the Catholic church right
before the Lord returns there'll be an
apostasy everyone with me
there everyone let me there let me show
you what was sent to me all right so let
me show you what was sent to me right
I'll get you the links and I'll try to
comment on it in the not so distant
future maybe sometime next week if God
Wills so here I'm going to show you
share my screen this is from the Sam
shimun page started by others but I took
over because they have my name in my
image and I don't want them to put
heretical teaching in my name here it is
this is it right here see it and I'll
give you the articles let me enlarge it
this was sent to me
there all right let's
see
Raphael Lea that's what he says to
me see if I can do
this all right anyway can't do
it hello Sam my name is Rafael and I
live in Porto pugel I watch your videos
daily and learn a lot from hey man this
guy's a scholar I'm a Catholic and a
scholar of the holy church in lives of
the Saints
here's an interesting article about the
statements made by some popes of the
past regarding the crisis the church
will go through in the last days so here
it is so what did I say I had said that
there have been Catholic Mystics and
Visionaries that already said there's
going to be a crisis in the Catholic
church and the Antichrist will arise in
the Catholic
church so why are you Catholics freaking
out I know others who hate the Catholic
Church will use this say see the
Catholic Church IS F
but here are Catholic Mystics and
Visionaries and popes saying that the
Lord already warned them Antichrist will
come out of
church not because it's a false church
but because he seeks to corrupt it and
that will be the sign of Jesus's return
physically bodily to judge the living
and the dead get everyone out of here
who's a troll please so here it is let
me share it with you on Rumble then I'm
GNA show you the
screen all right let me share it with
you here and then I'll show you the
other article
right
here the 100-year test now
ironically right look what it says and
that's why this video I watched today by
this brother shocked me because he
appealed to the same passage Luke
188 I'll do something Lord willing maybe
next week on these
prophecies claiming the Catholic Church
will be
hijack
within right before Jesus returns
physically bodily through so now watch
here on October 13 can you see the
screen can you see the screen let me
know I gave you the
link and I'm G Play a clip on October 13
1884 Pope Leo the 13 just after
celebrating Mass turned pale collapsed
as though
dead those standing nearby rushed to
hiside they found alive but the pontiff
looked frightened he then recounted
having a vision of Satan approach ing
the Throne of God boasting that he could
destroy the church according to Pope Leo
the 13th the Lord reminded him that his
church was imperishable s then replied
grant me one century and more power of
those who will serve me and I'll destroy
it our Lord granted him a 100 years the
Lord re then revealed the events of the
20th century to Leo the 13 He Saw Wars
immorality genocide and apostasy on a
large scale 1884 h immediately following
the disturbing Vision he sat down and
wrote the prayer to St Michael for
decades it was prays prayed at Mass
until the
1960s like many of the church's
spiritual defenses it was discontinued
in the second half of the 20th century
now I'll do a session reading all of
this
okay documented Visions announcing the
apostasy over a hundred years some say
even several hundred years before it
happened and they say that the Third
Secret of Fatima someone sent me a
comment I pinned it I didn't read it but
I'll look into it that when the Our Lady
of Fatima appeared the Third Secret
third mystery of Fatima was that there
would be an
infiltration and I believe the comment
said Masons would infiltrate the
Catholic church and try to corrupt it
now I'll get to that in time just give
me some time guys there's too much on my
plate so that's one article he sent
me now let me show show you what else he
said so Catholics why are you
troubled meaning even out though The
Outsiders hate the church and say it's
corrupt and use this your own popes
Visionaries and Mystics
announced that Satan would infiltrate
the Catholic church with the Lord's
permission to try to destroy it so if
these prophecies are genuine and they're
being fulfilled that's all the more
proof that Catholic Church is not
false it's because Catholics are poorly
catechized and don't know their Rich
tradition you get my
point now does that mean I'm saying
these other churches are false
absolutely not it's not what I'm saying
I will never say these churches are
false Orthodox church or S I never
you'll never hear that from me but it's
the Catholics who should say all this is
doing is fulfilling what our visionary
Mystics and popes said what happen
because the Lord Jesus revealed it to
them and their words are coming to pass
showing this is true and of the Lord you
get
it why is it troubling you I don't get
it does someone like me need to tell you
I'm a I'm a new kid on the Block I just
joined the debate I just entered the f I
don't know
much I am learning relearning unlearning
right
you guys should be in the Forefront
knowing your tradition you've grown up
Catholics I hated the Catholic church I
hated the Orthodox Church I thought
they're corrupt and are the
devil anyway he goes on to say this
right
here the second one the subject is vast
and the rabbit hole goes very
deep if you are interested I suggest
looking into the prophecy about the
church from St John BOS Padre poo
he even had Visions announcing this
Padre of
P blessed and Katherine Emer and he sent
me another article among others as well
as the apparitions of our lady in
Fatima Garabandal and
majori as the true bride of Christ holy
church will also suffer its Calvary but
in the end the promise of perpetuity
made by our Lord will prevail other
articles on this subject he just sent me
this one God bless you and happy
birthday so now watch this one that he
sent
me okay watch this one that he sent
me this is the other one now let me get
you the link there it is right there
guys
see Frank if these are prophecies that
are being fulfilled that means
these are true Revelations of Christ
Frank which means that Christ already
revealed to the church there'll be an
onslaught within but that's not because
the church is false it's being attacked
so that Satan can try to destroy it you
okay Frank you're not getting it on Raga
all right so you see the link I just
sent you the link there let me enlarge
it all
right Prophecies of blessed Anna
Katherine Emer now Lord willing I will
do a session on these
prophecies right
Stigmata Anna lives off the Eucharist
alone for 12 years I pray the spirit
fill us to do that you know how holy
you'll be and righteous and pure and how
healthy your body will feel from the
poisons of the food that we eat
so she has
dreams or visions I should say it will
be hijacked I heard that lucif ER will
be freed again for a while 50 or 60
before the year 2080 all right there you
go a false church and wicked men
scheming against the Catholic Church
doing much harm both in her own time and
in the future there you go so she saw it
so we'll do this we'll talk about it in
time so you got the Articles
right exactly Angela
exactly
right exactly now I'm G to play a few
minutes of this we're gonna
who's a monster man who are you
talking all right I'm going to play a
clip from this now he's a deoc Catholic
again I you probably know him more than
I I was just watching it today and he
also mentions that Luke 188 is cited as
indicating that even when our Lord
Returns the faithful will be few and far
between because there's going to be a
major satanic attack that will separate
the wheat from the chaff the men from
the boys the women for the girls I pray
we are wheat we are men and women who
stand because the Lord says when a son
of man returns shall he find any faith
left on the earth that's a rhetorical
question meaning that when he returns
there'll be few faithful
remaining that's your journey Yar don't
ask
me so you're aware about that say I'm
learning so now let me play this clip
I'm going to play some clips here okay
watch here few Clips
here listen to what he says now he's a
devout Catholic Timothy Gordon it says
he has a PHD right anyway Timothy Gordon
look what he says about what the pope
said now he's a devout Catholic now he's
mentioning this in light of the
Apocalypse he mentions that there
was I believe a cardinal that he named
in the session because I just watched it
that said we possibly are in the end
times we're possibly in the end times
and if we are then that means the
prophecies that the final Pope would
actually bring about the Antichrist it
may be that time he goes we don't know
only God knows that their hour so he
gives his comments
well let me go back to what Cardinal uh
to what the pope said in Singapore to a
bunch of mostly Muslim school children
all religions are paths to reach God
that's that's heresy that is an
anathematized heresy it's been
anathematized by several
councils by the you know Pi the 9th um
Syllabus of Errors see Pius the nth
syllabus errors says that there are many
paths that reach God is heresy condemned
by the Catholic Church which is getting
that from scripture because has to be
faithful to scripture now look what he
says by several popes uh statements by
the longstanding teaching of the church
just teach all religions are paths to
God well what about paths to reach God
through they'll see their ER okay so
let's read on watch here they are to
make a comparison like different
languages different dialects to get
there now that that is once again this
is not the first time I'm saying it a
materially heretical statement by
Francis even if you could stretch that
first sentence paths to reach god
consider they're not saying paths to God
the second statement is just materially
heretical all religions are not like
different languages which because a
different language be speaks the Same by
the way Timothy Gordon please don't flag
me copyright law allows for fair use of
excerpts and I'm giving a shout out May
the Lord increase your viewership I'm
know you wouldn't do that but I just
have to be careful L YouTube comes after
me in propositional sense sentence so if
we talk about what is the symbolic Logic
the propositional value of a truth claim
in English or Spanish it's equivalent
it's identical you see what he's saying
you can say the exact same thing in
different languages but to say that
these religions are all different
languages means that they're all saying
the same thing about God and that's not
true Pope Francis is saying that all the
world's religions with this analogy he's
expressly saying that all world's
religions are equally correct see that
that's that's
heresy he says in the third sentence but
God is God for
everyone play two minutes here and then
the last minute listen what he says what
if you're talking polytheists what
they're calling Gods aren't even Gods
they're demons and by the definition of
God God's godhood he has to be all-
knowing all powerful all
spatial some other adjectives that begin
with the the prefix
Omni since Greek Gods problem is
precisely that if there are multiple
gods you're not even dealing with Gods
like like the Greek gods because if Zeus
is all powerful and he tells you to do
it understand what he's saying when you
acknowledge Hinduism as a path what do
you do with the gods and goddesses of
Hinduism it's like the gods and
goddesses of the Greeks and what did
Paul say what did Paul say about that
Paul said that the gods worship by the
pagans are demons
if you go read the Greek version of
Psalm 965 which is Psalm 955 it says the
gods of the nations are demons are
devils and if you read 1 Corinthians 10
19-22 1 Corinthians 101 19-22
specifically verse 20 Paul tells us
Idols aren't aren't anything at all but
these Idols have demons it's the demons
that are associated with the idols
because the gods and goddesses of the
nations are Satan and demons appearing
as these gods and
goddesses and that's applicable to
Hinduism so Hinduism cannot be a path to
God because you have demons that appear
as gods and goddesses and some of these
gods and goddesses are horrendous right
and contest what Pope Francis said
because Hinduism steeped in demons and
so this what he's saying he's saying how
can you say this is material heresy all
these pths are different languages to
the same God how K
Shiva Brahma Vishnu if you start to
fight saying my religion is more
important than yours this is what the
pope said look at us mine is true and
yours isn't where will this lead us so
he's telling Catholics that they can't
say that their religion is more
important and more true than false Faith
he's just saying there is no one true
Faith very directly Okay so there is
only one God and each of us has a
language to arrive at God some of us are
Shake that's not a a strictly speaking
monotheism Muslim yeah that's a
monotheism I want to address that in a
second Hindu that's a polytheism
Christians that's the one true Faith
okay we we get the point so he's saying
that this was wrong now that this
document is balanced and thoroughly
biblical are you ready thoroughly
biblical now I can't say that for Pope
Francis okay I'm trying to be honest
what Pope Francis said was not correct
he could have said these ways will lead
to the true God in Jesus Christ and it's
Jesus Christ who will save you because
he died for you because he loves you now
if he had said that Bingo bam but he
didn't say that he didn't say that folks
so Catholics out of love for you I'm
telling you don't apologize guys don't
excuse it call it for what it is you
understand my point